0.25 so a quarter of a percentage point
uh interest rates have just been
increased uh by that much they are now
up to 1.25
that is the highest that they have been
uh since 2009 and it's also the fifth
time the fifth successive meeting at
which the npc the monetary policy
committee here at the bank of england uh
has decided to raise interest rates so
put all of that together and there's
clearly one direction it's worth saying
though i'm just kind of scanning as as
the news comes through because we'll
also get the minutes on precisely which
members have voted for what it's worth
saying you know a lot of people thought
there was a good chance that the bank
might go even faster than that raising
rates by a full half a percentage point
remember last night the federal reserve
that's the america's central bank they
raised their interest rate their main
interest rate by 0.75 percent so the
bank of england doing this some people
will look at them and ask the question
are they moving a little bit too slowly
given what we're seeing in the united
states
they will argue that this is a kind of
sense check that there are lots of risks
for the economy at the moment that when
you look at the state of uh the uk yes
there is inflation incredibly high at
the moment but there is also the risk
that we're facing a big energy price
shock that's putting down on demand and
that means that people have their own uh
issues to face with uh to deal with at
the moment um it's worth saying that
just looking through some of the details
that we're seeing in the minutes um they
have also said that they are going to be
expecting inflation or at the moment
they're existing at forecast says
inflation's going up above 10 percent
they're now saying they expect it to go
up towards 11 so even higher than they
previously uh thought uh and that's uh
also that gdp in this quarter that we're
at the moment is going to fall i would
say that's kind of slightly more of a
statistical uh one of those statistical
aberrations because we have an extra
bank holiday in this quarter and there's
a lot of other things going on but it
does underline the fact the economy
right now is not doing tremendously well
we are if not stagnating uh then
potentially kind of having very weak
growth right now and that is part of the
explanation for why the bank although
they are facing uh inflation so high at
the moment nine percent going up they
say now uh to 11
why they've only raised interest rates
by 0.25
but as i say a lot of people will look
at them and say
perhaps you could have gone even faster
even further even though there are many
people across the country who will feel
the impact of this of course on your
mortgages it will of course increase
savings rates as well but a lot of
people in high levels of debt at the
moment say this will affect them so
that's the decision that we just had
from the bank of england uh interest
rates up by 0.25 percent to 1.25 percent
a six three vote so there are three
three members of the monetary policy
committee who are pushing for slightly
higher interest rates but nonetheless
there's nine members on there it's a
majority decision uh it was six three uh
in favor of 0.4 0.25
increase in interest rates and ed we
were i was talking to one one of our
guests about the historical perspective
on this it it will seem high to those
who have got mortgages since 2009
because their mortgages will be on a
lower rate for example but if we look
back to the 80s and 90s
rates were far far higher weren't they
it's it's it's nowhere near what it used
to be in the past i mean think back to
before the financial crisis i mean it's
now quite a long time ago 2008 2009. but
at that point what people thought
described as the kind of neutral level
for interest rates so the kind of normal
level was about five percent a little
bit over five percent we are now down at
1.25 it is still
up until that crisis we haven't seen
interest rates below two percent in the
history of this place since 1694 so you
have to go back a long way uh to find
them well there is nothing similar in
terms of our kind of interest rates at
the moment but it is worth also saying
although that headline level of interest
rates is at 1.25 that's very low
also remember that across the country
levels of debt are significantly higher
uh than they were you know a few decades
ago so the impact that people face as a
result of that is more significant of
course also house prices are a lot
higher and a lot of other things have
changed too but yeah in historical
comparison this is still a very low
level of interest rate but by the same
token look at inflation up at nine
percent that's the highest it's been uh
since the early 1980s expected to go
comfortably into double digits that's
the bank of england's new forecast and
that is why a lot of people worry that
we might be facing a repeat of the 1970s
and what happened to the 1970s you had
inflation very high you had the bank of
england and indeed remember this is now
an independent central bank so they have
their committed decide interest rates in
the past it used to be a kind of
political decision but you had interest
rates trying to chase inflation and not
getting it down uh for a long time and
as a result you had a period of
stagflation as people call it so high
inflation low growth the worry and the
people will look at the bank and say are
you you know are you aware of this worry
the worry is there's a chance that the
uk could well repeat that and indeed
other countries around the world because
we're not the only country with high
inflation but worth just saying jane
inflation here higher than any other
country in the g7 so higher than any
other major country right now and if
it's heading up to 11 it could well be
the highest of all so the fact that the
bank of england is raising rates more
slowly than many other central banks
including the federal reserve there will
be some eyebrows raised about this